on this dry and parched patch of land
tonight a fire rages
hankly common is the scene of a major
incident as hundreds of firefighters
battle the blaze which has caused fear
in surrey
dozens of people were forced to evacuate
their homes as the common satellite for
the second time this week many seek
shelter in the local pub i've never seen
it this close
to us it's
there's a lot of people that are worried
and it's
it's a bit closer to home than we
normally see the smoke out there was
making your eyes water and all sorts of
things so yeah it was quite intense
but after another hot day in the south
fires emerged across the capital too the
wind encouraged the spread of three big
wildfires which put the fire service
under immense pressure
in thames mead smoke swooped across
homes and businesses but by the evening
65 firefighters managed to get it under
control
in east london a fire at ramy marsh
spreading over 20 hectares raged for
hours before 70 firefighters managed to
extinguish it
and then a country park in west london
was satellite which saw over a hundred
firefighters tackling the blaze which
spread rapidly
but it was this inferno's big plumes of
smoke that billowed across the west and
onto runways at heathrow visibility was
poor but the airport confirmed there was
no impact on scheduling
although these wildfires weren't as
damaging as the one earlier in the week
their fierce nature there's a reminder
of the severe disruption they could
cause to our infrastructure
whilst all the fires across the capital
are now under control the blaze at
surrey remains and police warn there's a
risk it could spread even more overnight
with another warm and dry day on the
cards it's a danger this rural landscape
faces in saman rashid sky news